the opening scene we are introduced to a
man named Park dongwan who along with
his wife Jung Yi and their son suchan is
in the process of moving into a new
building however they discover that a
car is blocking their path the owner of
the car is apparently unwilling to come
out and move it enraged Park repeatedly
calls out to the owner until a man named
young man sue finally walks out and
removes the vehicle park reprimands the
guy for his careless parking but mansue
remains cold saying that he didn't do
anything wrong instead he claims that
Park should apologize for disturbing his
Sunday's sleep following this the family
begins transporting their possessions
into the building Park takes this time
to meet his new neighbors one of them is
a single mother named Miss o who works
tirelessly throughout the day before
heading to work she advises her son Lee
seung-hoon to avoid talking to strangers
after completing the shifting process
Park and his family relax in their new
apartment the following morning sushan
is playing with his marble when he
demonstrates an intriguing observation
to his parents the marble always seems
to roll down in the same direction this
raises Park's curiosity leading him to
wonder whether the floor or the entire
building is tilted it in the next scene
Park begins his day by preparing for
work but before heading to the office he
decides to stop by a nearby gym with the
intention of becoming a member however
as plans change when he discovers that
the Gym's trainer is none other than the
Arrogant mansue the following day park
takes his family to a photo studio to
have a family portrait taken to his
surprise he discovers that mansu is the
owner of the shop mansu explains that
the gym belongs to a friend and his true
profession is actually photography
hearing this park becomes visibly
annoyed after the photo session the
family enjoys a delightful dinner at an
upscale restaurant Park drinks a glass
of wine to celebrate the fact that he
has finally bought an apartment
unfortunately he becomes so drunk that
they have to call for a taxi the driver
is none other than mansu that evening a
heavy downpour occurs leading to a crack
forming in the glass of the building
mansu notices it in the morning and
tries to investigate but as soon as he
touches the cracked door it shatters
completely shortly after a neighbor
arrives and chastises him for his
carelessness meanwhile Park notices that
there are cracks in the floor caused by
the rain this worries him so he
immediately reports the issue to the
municipal Council urging them to take
appropriate repairing action however the
council informs him that the repair can
only proceed with the consent of all
residents determined to address the
problem Park gathers all the neighbors
for a discussion but unfortunately the
situation devolves into arguments over
trivial matters the following day Park's
co-workers arrived for a small gathering
at his new home as they approach the
building they notice mansue covering the
broken door with plastic he also
expresses his concern about the cracks
on the ground giving them a negative
impression of the building Park however
disregards man sees words into ushers
his co-workers inside following this
they proceed to talk to each other over
some food and drinks as the evening
grows late two of the co-workers bid
their goodbyes and leave but as the
other two Xiang Hyun and Yoon Zhu are
too drunk to drive Park asks them to
spend the night at his place the next
day Yang Yi and Su Chan are heading
towards the grocery store when they
realize that they have left their
shopping trolley at home they try
contacting Park to bring it but he is in
a deep sleep and doesn't answer his
phone as a result Yang Yi asks her son
to return home to retrieve the trolley
meanwhile sung Hyun hastily rushes out
of the house to see as an important
meeting to attend he immediately hires a
cab but soon after he realizes that he
has forgotten his bag at Park's house
which prompts him to take a u-turn on
the other hand mansue is seen knocking
on each neighbor's door to inquire about
running water but receives no response
making him think that nobody is at home
however sunghoon is actually at home
abiding by his mother's rule of not
speaking to strangers mansue then
decides to go up to the roof to inspect
the water tank meanwhile his son sunte
who is smoking there quickly hides upon
seeing him mansu notices an older man
watering plants in the next building
making him realize that the water
problem is specific to their apartment
as he proceeds to leave suddenly the
ground begins to tremble exposing a
sinkhole beneath the building the
sinkhole starts engulfing the entire
building but eventually stops when the
hole becomes narrow sung Hyun who is in
the cab tumbles into the sinkhole and
lands on the roof of the sinking
building as the building continues to
descend he instinctively keeps pressing
the accelerator causing the car to
plummet and ultimately land on a or Park
who happens to be at the same floor
quickly assists sunghyun in escaping
through the car window after this they
rescue yunju who is trapped beneath the
furniture moments later man sue who was
previously trapped on the building's
roof also falls onto Park's floor as the
group gathers Park begins searching for
his son but man city reveals that he saw
suchan in the elevator he believes the
boy must have managed to escape however
mansu is worried about the safety of his
son the group then rushes to his
apartment and discovers that a pair of
shoes is missing this makes them assume
that sunte is somewhere else safe
following this they head to the roof in
hopes of getting help however the
sinkhole is so massive that their cell
phones don't catch any signal and
shouting is just a waste of energy just
then they hear a voice pleading for help
upon following the sound they discover
siente trapped beneath some debris and
they immediately help him out outside
the sinkhole is surrounded by the police
and Rescuers they try to descend into
the sinkhole but the ground trembles
forcing him to retreat as the situation
deteriorates the police make the
decision to evacuate all residents
including young Yi and sunghoon's mother
elsewhere the trapped group builds a
fire and starts rationing the available
food the next morning The Rescuers
deploy a drone into the sinkhole but it
loses control and crashes onto the roof
of the sinking building upon finding it
the trapped group becomes excited
assuming the device will capture their
presence at the same time a part of the
building collapses causing the roof to
tilt everyone except for sunghyun
manages to hold on and secure their
position Yoon Zhu then takes a daring
Risk by grabbing a wire and throwing it
towards sunghyun with the assistance of
mansu and park they then managed to pull
sunghyun back onto the roof however the
matter worsens when the wire snaps
resulting in mansu falling into the
muddy pit in a valiant attempt to save
his father xiuntae jumps into the mud
but tragically he also starts sinking
now with time running out Park comes up
with a clever plan he rushes to his
bedroom and shatters the windows this
allows the mud to flow into the room
hence saving the father and son's life
amidst this the Drone surprisingly
receives a signal and flies out of the
sinkhole this makes The Rescuers aware
about the presence of survivors inside
upon on investigating further they
discover that Su Chan had a phone with
him when he entered the building they
track its location and unfortunately
learn that the boy is still trapped
inside the following day The Rescuers
make efforts to convince the residents
of the neighboring building to allow
them to demolish the pillars as a
precautionary measure if the pillars
aren't destroyed there is a high risk of
the building collapsing into the same
sinkhole initially the residents refused
to comply but one elderly man steps up
and delivers a touching speech
eventually convincing all of them look I
don't know where I am right now or who I
am but just due to damn do it damn it
Tim inside the sinkhole mansu claims
that there's no one left in the building
as he had thoroughly checked all the
rooms before the incident occurred a few
moments later The Rescuers utilized
small parachutes to drop essential
supplies into the sinkhole the supplies
include food flashlights oxygen water
batteries and a satellite phone Park
immediately grabs the phone to dial his
wife's number but before that the phone
starts ringing as he answers the voices
of The Rescuers can be heard on the
other end young Yi interrupts the
conversation and urges Park to search
for suchan unbeknownst to
suchan is inside one of the cars parked
in the parking lot the group proceeds to
secure a rope intending to send park
down into the Elevator Shaft Outside The
Rescuers deploy a crane into the
sinkhole unfortunately their operation
is halted as the upper portion of the
adjacent building collapses blocking
access to the sinkhole completely inside
Park somehow manages to reach the
parking lot but sadly the group loses
their grip on the Rope moreover the rain
Pours Down which causes the water level
in the parking lot to gradually rise
meanwhile suchian is crying for help
when he sees seung-hoon coming out of a
large pipe the boy gets out of the car
to follow seung-hoon but a large debris
Falls and blocks the path Park's leg
also sustains an injury from falling
debris yet he pushes through the pain
determined to find suchian he calls out
his son's name and the boy responds Park
then follows the sound and finally
rescues suchan as the father-son duo
rejoice in happiness they notice
something in one of the ceilings holes
it turns out to be Miss oh who sadly
informs them that sunghoon is passed
away at the same time Park notices the
flooding water and asserts that they
have to escape but miso insists they
leave without her she is sure that her
frail body won't allow her to climb up
before parting ways though Miss o cuts a
lock of sunghoon's hair and gives it to
park asking him to deliver it to the
boy's mother when they're rescued
following this park carries his son on
his back and starts climbing up the pipe
once they reach the building's Cliff he
screams for his friends the trapped
group hears the calls and immediately
Springs into action with combined effort
they somehow managed to pull the
father-son duo up after this the group
heads towards the roof and shockingly
learns that the sinkhole has been
blocked to make matters worse the water
level is gradually engulfing the place
realizing that they don't have much time
left the group begins searching for
bottles and other objects that can serve
as flotation devices in the rising water
not long after mansu finds a large water
tank which he names the Yellow Submarine
everyone quickly enters except for mansu
who bravely chooses to remain outside
risking his life to secure the tank lid
as water engulfs the place the tank
begins Rising towards the surface
however at one point it gets entangled
in some wires yunju notices this and
suggests vigorously shaking The Vessel
so they all jump inside the tank and
somehow manage to disentangle it
unfortunately a few seconds later
disaster strikes again a steel beam
impales the tank allowing water to flow
inside acting quickly the group uses all
of their strength to push the steel beam
but to no avail fortunately the heroic
command suit shows up with an oxygen
supply and joins in the effort he pulls
the steel beam from outside and finally
manages to dislodge it seung-hoon then
inserts his hand into the hole
desperately trying to stem the flow of
water meanwhile mansu attempts to hold
on to the tank hoping to ascend with it
but he fails to catch it fortunately his
foot gets Tangled with the wires from
the tank which drags him up with the
rest of the team as the group reaches
the surface they breathe a sigh of
relief however their happiness is
short-lived as they notice another hole
in the tank posing a new threat reacting
swiftly mansu climbs onto the tank and
opens the land in the meantime The
Rescuers also spot them and quickly
dispatch a crane to their aid but this
the group is finally rescued after 48
Hours of being in hell in the aftermath
of these tragic events young Yi is
joyously reunited with her family and
park presents sunghoon's hair to his
grieving mother as a token of
remembrance somehow I don't think that
would make me feel any better several
months later mansu and his family visit
sung Hyun and yoonju who have found a
new home together in a trailer they
gather near the river enjoying delicious
meals and drinks suddenly a loud
explosion occurs nearby scaring the life
out of them however it turns out to be a
spectacular display of fireworks which
brings a smile to their faces once again
despite the obvious PTSD they're all
experiencing
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching